[Musique]
nous allons et la mort en père et a vécu
l'enfer qui est avec nous son spectacle
public ou pas il sera à l'olympia
florent peyre les 18 et 19 février et
quand même éloquent place patrice
exceptionnel c'est le gros kiff noir
mais je les fais un petit peu là en
descente j'ai fait prendre à partie de
dany boon prennent mois de décembre il
m'a fait ce cadeau là j'ai pris mes
marques et là où j'en étais bon lui il a
fait de moi moi je fais deux jours donc
mais je serais content toujours à
l'olympia déjà c'est fou ce sera donc 18
et 19 février
est ce que tu vas faire les chroniqueurs
de touche pas à mon poste dont d'un
spectacle dans le spectacle parce que tu
les fais tous les mêmes quelquefois nous
en faire deux trois cinq ans si vous
voulez mon équipe et je sais que tu me
dit aussi sacré vu dans une part j'ai
même été le premier jour je suis plus le
meilleur mais j'ai été le premier je
sais pas qui attend ma mère m'a mis des
accessoires comme on n'avait rien
préparé à tanger s'est plu à temps qui
tu veux que je fasse devant les premiers
qui tu veux je pense que terminer il va
dit fait savoir bouge pas ah oui
d'accord ben on voit les gens ayant déjà
on sait que c'est pas isabelle morini
bosc
tu sais que j'ai failli ne pas arriver à
jeter à la bibliothèque la grille de
palu à la bibliothèque la surprise à
l'adversaire on l'avait reconnu a déjà
jean pons faire de avec celle là ah oui
oui je sais mais c'est possible
alors on peut faire non mais vraiment à
shakhtar en colère
j'adhère complètement à giles battant
j'aime à dire on a tout le monde
john tessier la veille wallon jean hamel
donne c'est en 1958 que 11 i 3 je peux
en faire une santé rugby sans perruque
tiens ta votre cabas tu as bien sûr
c'est benjamin castaldi est ok je te le
fais à beaubery abattage croit savoir
qui c'est ouais tu veux ma place la date
avait bien longtemps je sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'instant est celle de la famille et
dans un resto à chaque fois que je suis
innocent je fais tu sais c'est
physiquement enfin tu manges pas dans tu
fais ça pour ma meilleure tous les jours
y a que moi qui fais moi tous les jours
et qui perdent pas qu'ils envoient
l'assumons florent dans un instant tu va
nous montrer un talon que tu as tu fait
du mental y est non mais c'est vrai en
plus à l'effet inverse et il va faire
une expérience incroyable prendre à
quelqu'un dans le public et il fait un
truc de fou voilà il est aussi mentalist
florent sais pas si tu m'en faire à
l'olympia mais que va nous faire une en
fait pas dans ce spectacle là mais je
sais pour le deuxième spectacle ce sera
axée mentalist va nous faire ça dans un
âge où on fait comment